what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime opera and we finally received
confirmation about the attack on titan
season 4
release date season 4 of attack on titan
will be the final season of the series
and the episodes were initially supposed
to start airing in october
of 2020 but the global health crisis
caused major delays and for a while we
were afraid that the final season of
attack on titan would be pushed
back all the way to next year thankfully
we recently found out that attack on
titan will in fact be
back near the end of 2020
in this video i will discuss the final
season of attack on titan and the insane
ending
of the story itself so definitely stay
tuned
before we begin a huge thank you to
gentian impact for sponsoring
this video gentian impact is a new open
world
action rpg game available on pc android
ios
and playstation 4. i recommend the pc
version
the big screen makes the adventure more
immersive the graphics are freaking
stunning
and it is so much fun to run climb swim
and literally glide through the air
across this beautiful open world
playing gentian impact is honestly like
being inside a fantasy
anime world and i love it there are 24
different playable characters and
depending on which character you play
you can use
awesome sword combos magic combos and
much more
but the absolutely coolest aspect of
gentian impact
is its elemental combat system in the
game
characters have control over one of
seven natural
elements including cryo dendro pyro
hydro anemo electro ngo
depending on which element you control
and how your element interacts with the
element of your opponent
you can create awesome combat strategies
the game launched on september 28th of
2020 so
now is the absolute best time to start
playing
if you start right now you'll receive
incredible launch awards
these include 1600 primo gems when you
reach adventure rank 7
10 acquaint fate when you reach
adventure rank 1 and another 10 acquaint
fate when you reach adventure rank 10.
and when you reach adventure rank 20 you
will receive a 4 star character
barbara to receive the launch awards
just create an account and use the code
in the description try it out right now
to download the pc version which i
recommend
click that link in the description
gentian impact is also available on
mobile in the app store
and google play now after a lot of
speculation
and genuine confusion about the attack
on titan season 4
air date on september 24th it was
confirmed that the final season of
attack on titan will begin airing on
december
7th of 2020. this is about two months
after a fall anime season show would
normally begin
airing but with the widespread delays
due to the current global crisis
i for one am happy that the delay wasn't
even longer
if you are an anime only fan you may be
wondering
what you are in for with the final
season of attack on titan
without spoiling anything i can tell you
that it is going to be absolutely insane
and if they adapt the manga well
attack on titan will definitely become
an undisputed
modern classic anime if you're wondering
whether you should be excited for this
season
yes yes you should so get ready because
it's going
to be absolutely epic but
if as an anime only you don't want any
spoilers from this point forward
you should click away from this video
because now we are going to get
into the attack on titan's source
material the manga
and we'll talk about how the attack on
titan series will eventually
end so if you are a manga reader like me
you know that as of this final season
release date announcement
the attack on titan manga which is the
source material for the anime
is not actually over in the past anime
series that ended before the manga came
to a proper conclusion
often chose to stray away from the manga
and create a completely different
ending to the story the original
fullmetal alchemist anime
is a famous example of this oh and game
of thrones is another
famous example and we all know how that
turned out
thankfully even though the attack on
titan manga is not yet
over it is definitely in its final
stages
now we don't know the exact number of
chapters that the story has left
in my opinion it could be anywhere
between 5 and 10
more chapters on the other hand if isam
decides to really speed up the pace of
the story
or if he decides to make the last few
chapters longer we could
theoretically be looking at the manga
ending within the next few months
at any rate if things continue at their
current pace
the manga is likely to end around the
same time as the anime
maybe a bit sooner or a bit later but
either way
isam already knows exactly how he
intends to end the series
and he has definitely informed the anime
creators of that fact
so yes i expect the anime will complete
the events of the manga and i expect it
to stick to the ending that isayama has
been planning
i don't think that the anime will stray
away from the manga at least
not significantly and that actually
makes me very
happy because as tragic and
heartbreaking as these last
arcs of attack on titan have been they
have also given us some of the most
memorable and compelling instances of
character development
in recent memory i mean seriously just
think about how much reiner has
developed as a character how much
annie has changed and of course we can't
forget the man of the hour himself
aaron jaeger over the course of the
story attack on titan has done something
that popular manga series
rarely do it's definitely not unheard of
and we've seen other examples of this in
fiction
but in attack on titan the main
protagonist of the story aaron jaeger
went from being a hero to essentially
being the world's most ruthless
villain he went from a kid who vowed to
destroy the titans in order to protect
humanity
to a man who decided to use the titans
in order to destroy humanity
the biggest comparison that we always
keep hearing about is lelouch
from code geass as it's been over a
decade since code geass finished airing
i don't mind discussing the ending here
in code geass the main character ends up
turning himself
into a villain in order to turn all the
hatred of the world upon himself
his main goal is to stop the constant
war and suffering that the people of the
world have been dealing with
and the way that he chooses to do that
is by uniting all the different nations
and factions of the world
in their opposition to him once everyone
starts seeing him
as the main threat to global peace
lelouch orchestrates his own
assassination or pretend assassination
depending on your
interpretation of the ending the world
then watches as this hated villain is
killed before their eyes
and in the aftermath the once warring
nations decide to work together
in order to forge a new and better world
now i'm definitely oversimplifying the
code geass story for the sake of brevity
but the point is that lelouch's story is
a great example of the protagonist
undergoing a drastic character
development
and as aaron has made his own journey
from hero to villain
many have made the comparison between
lelouch and aaron and a lot of people
have speculated that perhaps aaron is
planning something similar to lelouch
if aaron turns himself into the world's
greatest villain and the single biggest
threat
to world peace then maybe all nations
can unite
in order to defeat him including the
aldians
once aaron is defeated maybe the various
nations of the world can finally learn
to live in peace
and since the aldians helped take aaron
down maybe the world will finally learn
to accept them
i thought that this was maybe a possible
endgame for aaron at first
but the more the story has progressed
the less likely this scenario
seems and it is worth noting that in
code geass there is no race of people
who can turn
into titans aaron being defeated would
not change the fact that most of the
world is afraid of aldians as a whole
because of their abilities to turn into
titans in terms of lelouch
he was definitely responsible for the
deaths of many people
including civilians but he didn't launch
a literal global apocalypse that has
already killed
a countless number of people and leveled
nearly an entire continent
if aaron had just taken out a bunch of
military targets
or if he had launched a limited rumbling
i could have seen the lelouch scenario
happening
but after chapter 131 i don't think that
aaron can be put in the same category as
lelouch
aaron has crossed the line and short of
some sort of time travel shenanigans
i don't think that aaron can ever go
back to being a hero who is just
pretending to be a villain
aaron's desire to protect parodies might
be noble
but his actions are the very definition
of super villainy
and chapter 131 really proved it and so
if we're not going towards a code geass
type ending
how will the attack on titan manga
finally end
there are probably three reasonable
possibilities with one additional
wild card option option one is that
aaron really will destroy the whole
world
except for parodies and then after that
he might use the founding titan's power
to erase
everyone's memories of the actual
apocalypse
and this would essentially give everyone
on the island except for aaron himself
a fresh start as they would believe that
they are the only humans
left in the world and since they
wouldn't remember why
they happened to be the only humans left
they wouldn't feel guilty
about what aaron has done option 2 is
that aaron will fail to destroy the
world because the alliance of scouts and
marland warriors
will stop him this option would
definitely give us an absolutely epic
final battle but can we really expect
mikasanarman to
actually go through with killing aaron
i'd have to see it
to believe it option 3 would involve
mikasa
and or armin somehow convincing aaron to
change his mind and stop the rumbling
before the entire world is destroyed
however pulling something like this off
without it being anticlimactic
would be a huge challenge and the final
option the one that would be a total
wild card
is directly related to emir fritz if
emir fritz decides that aaron's plan
isn't the right path
after all perhaps she will use the
founding titan's power to stop him
or maybe she can even turn back time
using the attack titan's future memories
maybe the story that we are seeing right
now is just one of many
possible futures that amir fritz saw
when she made her deal with aaron
because presumably when she made her
deal with aaron emir
also got access to his future memories
so maybe amir will decide to change this
future
by altering something in the past again
though
this wild card ending would be extremely
hard to pull off because after
everything that we just experienced
in these last several chapters having
amir just turned back the clock
could be quite anticlimactic it might
feel like
it was all a dream bro type of ending
and that would be a hard pill to swallow
for the fans of attack on titan
since many of us love attack on titan
precisely because of its ruthless
realism but no matter how the story
ultimately ends
attack on titan is already a modern
classic in my mind
this story is a masterful commentary on
human nature
and the nature of war and even though a
terrible ending can definitely ruin a
series
the attack on titan journey so far has
been an amazing experience
let me know what you guys think are you
excited for season 4
and how do you think that the story is
going to end
also do you think that the anime is
going to stray away from the manga
or are we in the clear because of the
fact that the manga
is almost over hit me up with your
feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more attack on titan content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar or maybe you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you